[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Juliette riaño
[Música]
en el mar Mediterráneo los barcos de
rescate patrullan continuamente aguas
internacionales buscan embarcaciones con
migrantes a la deriva por esa ruta
navegan cientos de botes que no tienen
la capacidad para llevar a estas
personas seguras a Europa las ong
trabajan para auxiliarlos pero ellos no
sólo se enfrentan a la furia del mar
también a los guardacostas libios esto
pasó en aguas internacionales contra la
tripulación de un barco de ayuda y las
personas que intentaban rescatar
un violento enfrentamiento en aguas
Internacionales El último sábado de
marzo un barco de la ong sos meditegane
se disponía a socorrer a una embarcación
de migrantes a la deriva frente a las
costas en libias pero la guardia costera
de ese país impidió la operación de
rescate Aunque para los voluntarios de
la ong son habituales estos encuentros
cara a cara este fue particularmente
violento después de una serie de
maniobras peligrosas los libios
efectuaron varios disparos
This is International waters
You Can't should
Evolution viking no pudo rescatar a unos
80 migrantes que necesitaban ayuda según
la ong que volaba por la zona varios de
ellos cayeron al agua algunos fueron
llevados de vuelta a Libia en
patrulleras de la guardia costera una
situación extremadamente peligrosa según
la presidenta de sos medite gané en una
entrevista para France 24
se supone que la guardia costera Libia
tiene la autoridad para la coordinación
de los rescates no solo no coordinan
estos rescates en absoluto sino que no
transmiten estas llamadas de Socorro
Este es el primer gran problema para
todos estos barcos en peligro en la zona
y luego nos impiden practicar
operaciones de rescate desde 2017 libie
y las ong de salvamento se enfrentan en
el Mediterráneo central
cabe recordar que la actividad de los
guardacostas libios es en gran parte
financiada por la Unión Europea la
organización internacional para las
migraciones estima que unas 1.417
personas perdieron la vida en la
considerada ruta más peligrosa en 2022
pero pese a hacer la ruta más peligrosa
gobiernos como el de Italia siguen
brindando sus fronteras para limitar la
llegada de migrantes y solicitantes de
protección a sus costas un flujo
creciente que no para al igual que las
causas que obligan a miles de personas a
huir hacia lo que consideran un mejor
presente esto pasa en aguas del
Mediterráneo central
finalmente Tierra Firme unos 190
migrantes a bordo del río barrens
esperan desembarcar lo harán después de
ser rescatados por el barco de la ong
médicos Sin fronteras frente a las
costas de Libia las autoridades
italianas aprobaron el puerto de Bari en
el sur del país para su llegada aquí son
recibidos por la cruz roja después de
miles de kilómetros de viaje desde
naciones tan alejadas como bangladesh
Pakistán Egipto eritrea y Siria también
llegaron algunos palestinos
previo a este día los migrantes
celebraban su seguridad a bordo
[Aplausos]
pero para los voluntarios hay riesgos
para su trabajo en cada ruta
nuestra principal preocupación sería que
no se tuvieran que nos impidan hacer lo
que estamos haciendo
estamos Rescatando personas en el mar
Mediterráneo y es algo que seguirá
pasando la gente seguirá usando esta
ruta
y ahora en cada operación de rescate se
sienten maniatados por la nueva política
del gobierno italiano
antes hacíamos uno dos tres rescates
antes de ir a desembarcar y ahora
hacemos solo uno el impacto en las
operaciones es grande porque con la
misma cantidad de salidas del año pasado
rescataríamos solo a un tercio de los
que auxiliamos
además no está incluido en el decreto
pero desde finales de 2022 no se están
dando puertos muy lejanos
esto también es claramente una
estrategia para mantener a las ong fuera
de la búsqueda y rescate
Y es que ahora los barcos deben respetar
la nueva norma en materia de operaciones
de salvamento marítimo Según la ley está
prohibido realizar rescates múltiples
aunque las ong tengan capacidad para
salvar a varias embarcaciones de
migrantes en peligro de naufragio
interpretado por médicos Sin fronteras
fue el primero en ser sancionado por la
nueva ley las autoridades italianas les
acusaron de no facilitar información
suficiente sobre uno de sus rescates
marítimos el resultado una multa de
hasta 10.000 euros y la inmovilización
del barco durante 20 días
muestra de que el tránsito por el
Mediterráneo no se detiene son los 4000
migrantes que llegaron a las costas
italianas en solo un fin de semana de
marzo según datos de la guardia costera
de allí el llamado de las organizaciones
de ayuda para que se les permita
auxiliar a más personas a la deriva y
evitar así más muertes durante el
tránsito y el dato de migración de la
semana un número récord de personas
cruzó la selva del daría en la frontera
natural que une a Colombia y Panamá en
lo corrido de 2023 El Ministerio de
seguridad pública de Panamá informó que
78,585 migrantes pasaron por el tapón lo
que supone una cifra cinco veces más
alta que la registrada en 2022
hasta aquí inmigrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrante f-24
sigan con más información en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]